walking through it how much did the
governor so first of all I have to give
full credit to truck yeah calm which is
a website which is a website that I
frequent and amazing yeah I used to know
an all-women hockey team known as the
mother puckers and I thought that was
the best name I ever heard yeah truck he
has a Jalopnik website and there's a kid
on there Andrew Collins who is a fanatic
for you know scouts and other kinds of
trucks and he started bidding for one of
these Humvees so I was following along
and to see how he did and I just found
this a fascinating story here you see
one of them now a lot of these were used
in battle in fact the government is
going to use auctioned off I should say
about 4,000 of these bad boys and they
started the auctions at $10,000 apiece
so the first round of auctions happened
over the last couple of days they
auctioned off 25 of them and the average
sale price was $30,000 and we're talking
about 29 if this was used in battle like
look at the size of these tires can they
can these car trucks even drive on the
highways uh well you could potentially
drive them on the highways if you could
get a license plate so unfortunately the
government's auctioning them off without
the right to license them for public
road use so hold on if you're gonna buy
them without the right to use them on a
road where he who use this so Collins
makes the point that you know a lot of
guys will pay thirty thousand and women
I'm sure pay thirty thousand dollars for
a pretty hopped up off-road vehicle for
a Polaris RZR for example do you become
very popular so why not spend $30,000 on
an absolutely badass Humvee I mean if
you look at the civilian models of these
the Hummer one that that are going now
for sale on ebay for fifty sixty
thousand dollars thirty thousand dollars
looks like a relative bargain now some
of the caveats include the fact that
there are no more guns unfortunately
they've taken all the weapons off of
these not only that but they I was just
thinking they could just partner with
the NRA
and make this sort of like a big
branding at the weapons because
obviously they're gonna take those off
but they even took the armor off the
armor plating that was on some of these
so they've really stripped them down but
they have very specific mechanical
checks on these they even do metal
metallurgical oil checks so you can see
what kind of shape the vehicles and and
they're gonna continue auctioning off
for the next couple of years the
government's gonna raise about a hundred
if they continue this average 120
million dollars with these sales alone
and she's got me thinking what else can
they sell hold on a second you said the
auctions that the original ask or the
auction the starting bid is 10 grand
they've been going for around 30 35 yeah
30 35 but how much did it cost them
originally to make these suckers well
that's a good question I'm not sure I'm
sure those pup figures are public but
I'm not sure exactly how much they're
very expensive and I guess if the
government's paying then they're twice
as expensive as they would have been to
begin with right the government feels
like $500 for a toilet seat so I'm sure
they were paying hundred grand for for
each one are you gonna bid on one no
because for me it's very difficult to
imagine going there you've got to pay
within three days and then go pick it up
you got to tow it back you need a really
big trailer for that so I'm not the kind
of baller that Andrew P Collins is